Hey guys, uh we have a Honda CRV 2010.
We going to do all key lost.
And first I want to show you how to cut
the key by the code and how where to
find it. So you got to find the code
from the glove box. Take off the the the
handle here
which is this one. It has two screw on
the top. There is a cover first.
Take off the cover. Two screw right
here. And all this will come off. All
right. And when it come off, you see
this one already. Take it off. But this
one, it has clips right here.
One clips right here on the back. Just
lift those clips. Three clips. One here.
One here and one on the side, I think.
Yeah. One here and one right here. Take
this one off.
All right. And then you have this one
here.
This one to hold the cylinder. Just take
it off too. Just peel it. Pull it. Come
off like this. And take this cylinder
off. All right. And if you check it, you
will see the code
right here.
And you need the last four
start with L385.
Always on Honda you need the last four.
I think the new cars 2014
15 sometime they put those code on the
middle in the front.
But most of them the last four and start
with the letter
and you go to the machine
go to Honda all key lost Honda and with
this code I will give you the correct
key cutter and this is the key already
cut it and now need to program it. Let
me connect the power show you how to
program it with the key tool max pro.
All right guys, we have a power and the
ignition is on and the security light is
that one blinking. That mean the key is
not programming. And this key when you
program the key the control automatic
is from 2007 to 2013 the same thing.
All right. So
we connect our tool to the OBD.
Go to key tool max pro. Go to imo
programming.
We go to Honda.
Start with letter H. Click Honda.
And then we select by type.
IMO system
and fly the IMO type.
IMO programming.
Click this one.
Click okay. Turn the ignition off. Keep
it on. Ignition on. Click okay. And here
we have add key loss. We have to do all
key lost.
All right.
Click all key lost. Turn the ignition
off.
Click okay. Turn the ignition on. Click
okay. How many keys you need? Uh we need
just one. Click okay. All
right. Now, it's going to ask you turn
the ignition off
and turn the ignition on. And now going
to tell you quick ignition off and on.
So you have to do it.
Okay. Ignition off and on. See ignition
off and on.
Keep it on. Now off.
On.
All right. Now check the security light
is off. All good. Click yes. Turn the
ignition off. Turn back on.
Now we wait.
All right. Complete. Good to go. And
now,
uhoh, this the battery.
All right. Let me connect. All right.
Start.
All right. Again, the battery. But
anyway, this is this is done. Uh the
control should work automatic now.
And yeah, that's it. This is how you get
the code and this how you program it.
And not sure, not always you will find
the code right here, but just in case
have a le is with you. All right,
thank you so much for watching. Please
like and subscribe and comment.